hi I'm Eric as you can tell I'm an
Adventist but I'm also the lead product
manager for Google products on the
world's first Android phone the t-mobile
g1 I'm here to tell you about the Google
goodies that come pre-loaded on this
phone there's search maps YouTube Gmail
contacts calendar and talk with an
Android phone everything is made simple
once you log in with a single sign in
all your google apps are available and
automatically synchronized with the web
you'll never have to login again you can
still protect all your stuff by creating
a screen lock pattern like this one
let's say you just met a new friend and
you want to add her as a contact let me
add Kate a cyclist I met on my ride last
weekend I can add Kate's phone number
email address and more
all google apps on Android are fully
synchronized so whatever you do on your
phone appears on your computer and vice
versa
so when I save Kate's info on the phone
in a matter of seconds it will appear on
the web this also means that all of
Kate's info is safe and always available
so even if you lose or break your phone
there's no need to panic because you're
always synced to your Google account so
after I log in and unlock my new Android
phone all my information is safe and
immediately available see Kate's info is
still there this is true for more than
just your contacts your calendar events
emails i.m chats are all synced between
the phone and the web if I create an
event on my computer like my bike ride
with Kate this afternoon shortly after
it will appear on my phone there I just
got a notification on my status bar the
status bar is where I get notified of
new emails new I am messages calendar
events text messages and so on in a
single swipe you get an update on
everything without the need to check
each and every one individually
oh here Kate's just confirmed our bike
ride plans to answer Kate I've got many
options and you can find them all on the
contacts app I can text I am
email and of course call I'll reply with
Google Talk
one last cool thing about Google Apps on
Android with just a couple of clicks you
can get a map of your contacts address
now Kate said we should meet near the
second cement anchor on the Golden Gate
Bridge I'm not exactly sure where that
is so I'll use Street View to find the
exact location
ah that's where it is
time to hit the road to learn more about
the Google mobile products on the
world's first Android phone the t-mobile
g1 visit mobile google.com slash Android